we're going through her day and
we're now ready to pick it back up with
um 8 p.m
well between noon and 8 p.m obviously
there's a million zooms at the moment
you know there's a multiple things
happening with my book um
my movie the white tiger and anomaly um
my hair care line so it was just all of
that but all of it on zoom obviously and
by 8 pm
i try to have dinner so it's sort of
early and i eat two meals um you know uh
we both don't cook
we both love to eat so we we love
donations if you love us please send us
food
because otherwise we'll starve
but a lot of our family cooks um so you
know we're always and we order in a lot
so it's great
and my mom's actually become a recently
um she never could cook my mom was
always like a working girl and never
really took to it but during quarantine
she started cooking and has been doing a
great job and i love how you speak about
your mom and your aunties and your
grandmother and how they exhibited a
wonderful sense of independence and it
made you think about you know kind of
how you are as a woman at work and in
relationships like i can totally run my
job and when it comes to my personal
life i feel like
everything is like animated and kind of
disorganized and my ages and my life are
never really at the same place in time
and
you know it's all very whimsical but i
don't feel like i can harness it the way
i can my professional life
um so i agree with you this but it took
me a long time to get there as well i
think i spent a lot of time in my 20s
trying to control my
personal life as much as i did my
professional life i was immaculate at my
professional life i could
compartmentalize i focused i was 100 and
everything you know i ran at the speed
that was required and i tried to do the
same thing but the matters of the heart
they don't listen to a schedule now do
they um and you know you i it's only in
my 30s that i came to a point where i
realized that
it's okay it's okay to ride the wave
when it comes to your home life and it's
okay to be a completely different person
and focused in your professional life
but you know you've just got to sort of
let let it organically happen
and not give up that control and i
remember very clearly sort of choosing
myself and saying okay let's take stock
of what i need
what do i need to feel happy what do i
need to feel productive what do i need
to be able to go to work and feel
inspired
and it's such a simple answer but you
need to feel happy and that happiness
cannot be dependent on someone else it
can't be someone else's validation
or you know in in everything so i
started bifurcating my life you know
this is home and this is work what i
feel at work will not come back home and
what i feel at home will not go back to
work and that really really helped me
find a sense of balance in both and i
think it just comes from like
first of all also maturity by the way
all of us i think when we're in our 20s
are like okay you know i got this and i
am under control and i can handle all of
it but it's really not i think when you
get to your 30s at least my experience
it really helped me find a sense of
balance it was so much more stable than
my 20s were
and you know
you met a prince
you met a man who was confident with his
own life and his own world and you could
be the full light that you are which
brings me to 10 p.m
what are you doing
so 10 p.m is usually like this is a work
week day okay so and this is outside of
you know my husband being home right now
but usually this would be a time when we
sit together we both come back from our
work you know we have a good meal we
hang out together watch a movie or i'll
read a book or it's just my
decompression time i need to be able to
have
before i get to bed some
at least two hours of being disconnected
from with the day and just
being with myself and it's usually when
dogs are around and you know i play
fetch with them or just something really
simple which helps you decompress and
then
then it's off to bed
and do you feel that way with nick like
now you get to be the fully realized
person that you are and it's appreciated
and welcomed
completely i mean nick is an extremely
secure self-assured man and that was the
most attractive thing about him and you
know that's not very common with most
men
um so it's really nice to have you know
he just he's my biggest cheerleader and
my biggest champion and my father was
like that my father was my loudest
cheerleader and you know now i'm married
to one so it's it's really
wonderful to have a partnership where we
both um are each other's champions but
also at the same time
you know we know what the other person
needs to
fly and that's just beautiful
well your life really inspires me
priyanka chopra jonas's
memoir unfinished is out now and it is
so wonderful please run out and grab
your copy thank you so much priyanka
thank you
[Music]
you